[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenos días buenas tardes todos y todas
podemos hablar en público de nuevo todos
y todas podemos hablar en público y si
le hacemos una pregunta podemos
realmente todos y todas hablar en
público
vamos a intentar comprobarlo pero vamos
a recordar primero ese examen en la
facultad que no pudimos dar esa lección
oral en el colegio que nos puso muy
tenso muy nerviosos esa presentación en
el trabajo que la pudimos hacer pero
transpiramos y realmente la pasamos muy
mal es a mí es a todos es algunos es a
los argentinos es a los altos es a los
flacos a los morochos a los rubios
porque tenemos miedo a la hora de hablar
en público lo primero que vamos a dejar
en claro es que no solamente es natural
tener miedo a la hora de hablar en
público sino que además es necesario y
no solo es natural y es necesario es
natural necesario estimulante
transitorio y totalmente individuo voy a
contar una pequeña historia hace miles
de años pero miles de años un abuelo de
abuelo de abuelo de nuestro abuelo
estaba cazando en la sabana africana
cuando de repente detrás de unos
arbustos un pequeño movimiento y aparece
lo que no esperábamos un tigre dientes
de sable éste no esté unos feroz no uno
simpático de acuerdo él nos quiere comer
nosotros queríamos comer nos fuimos
diseñados para hablar en público fuimos
diseñados para sobrevivir y frente a
esta situación nos quedamos paralizados
tenemos tres posibilidades fight flight
o freeze volar perdón pelear volar
ofrecernos fíjense que el tigre está a
punto de atacarnos sus garras ya
empezaron a salir sus pupilas se delatan
está por pegar el salto y de nuestro
lado emitimos mucha adrenalina a través
de las glándulas suprarrenales el hígado
trabaja una velocidad impresionante
los pulmones trabajan aire aire el
corazón no deja de palpitar se reduce la
sensibilidad del dolor tenemos tres
opciones ponernos a pelear
imposible digno de una utopía
de wonder woman o de ironman porque
pelear contra un mamífero de 150 kilos
sería una locura segunda opción flight
salir corriendo lo más probable es que
le garanticemos el almuerzo al querido
tigre que está feroz ya hambriento
freeze esto lo que nos sucedió hace
200.000 años y eso es lo que sucede hoy
arriba de un escenario o en un aula o en
una presentación nos quedamos fijados
nos quedamos congelados porque nuestro
cerebro es el que le dice a todo nuestro
cuerpo estás en peligro
te están evaluando se están examinando
te están probando y tenemos muy poco
tiempo para que el auditorio el público
o la clase quiera seguir invirtiendo el
tiempo en vos desde hace muchísimos años
trabajo con comunicación y esto lo que
más me gusta lo que le pasa al cuerpo no
es cierto hay diferentes miedos pero
esto del miedo a la hora de hablar en
público a veces es terrorífico pero a
veces es muy divertido y me animé a
agrupar a los comunicadores en seis
grupos de personas que sufren vamos a
hacerlo con un poco de humor no es
cierto tenemos el grupo de la pileta yo
sé que algunos me van a decir pero marco
yo lo paso mal no salen al escenario
salen de la pileta y muy papá 2
transpiración de pies a cabeza
totalmente
empapados no es cierto que podríamos el
grupo de los contorsionistas son esos
que cada dos minutos antes de la
presentación tienen que ir al baño pero
es un deseo de ir al baño todo
contorsionado absolutamente los músculos
tensos termina agotado este comunicador
tenemos el grupo de los palpita dores no
se agarran el corazón intentando frenar
una bomba cardíaca que está en un cuerpo
sellado absolutamente irracional no es
cierto me encanta el grupo de los
rockets no hablan a una velocidad
impresionante como los cohetes de lo más
acá esa velocidad y van cambiando de
color no rojo verde amarillo cianótico
porque no tienen respiración entonces
quieren finalizar la presentación
simplemente para
respiraron los deshidratados me encantan
no hola que tal y la boca se va
transformando en el desierto del sahara
no es cierto y por último extraordinario
hola que tal buenos dias como lengua es
una cosa que sube y baja seamos sinceros
vamos a ser totalmente sinceros hablar
en público
produce un verdadero espanto fisiológico
es divertido es terrible pero es un
espanto fisiológico no es cierto pero en
realidad destaca a los miedos son
irracionales y el miedo y si se alerta
que te está diciendo para sentarte a
trabajar sentarte a planificar sentarte
no el día antes a preparar un ppt sino
15 días antes a trabajar tu mensaje tus
discursos tu presentación tu negocio tu
examen
y la clave está acá en hacer un plan de
acuerdo a mí hay una frase que me
encanta que está por acá abajo que dice
nadie planifica fracasar si fracasa por
no planificar no cuántos países
tendríamos que recordar esta frase pero
hablar en público puede ser simple o
puede ser complejo como puede ser simple
o complejo jugar al fútbol o el hockey o
tocar el piano o tocar la guitarra la
simplicidad o la complejidad va a
depender de la rutina y en este siglo 21
parece que la rutina es contraria a la
creatividad vieron que rutina tiene mala
prensa porque
rutina es trazar una ruta cuando
trazamos una ruta estamos previendo
estamos planificando estamos
analizando posibles escenarios
rutina y creatividad no son antagónicas
y no existe un solo deportista ni un
solo científico ni un solo artista que
no tenga rutinas para sistematizar sus
acciones para multiplicar la cantidad de
veces que tiene que hacer ese movimiento
o ese pensamiento
por eso la idea es hacer un plan
planificar fíjense qué interesante esta
imagen no es cierto tenemos a una
comunicadora y tenemos un avión
los médicos los científicos de la salud
han identificado y nombrado
aproximadamente 200 miedos hay un montón
de miedo los conocemos la aracnofobia la
acrofobia la claustrofobia pero los dos
más comunes son estos el miedo hablar en
público y el miedo a viajar en avión
pero qué locura no el 90% de la
población mundial tiene miedo angustia
tensión o pánico a la hora de hablar en
público y sólo el 40 tiene angustia
atención miedo o pánico al volar en
avión es decir que 40 de cada 100
personas temen ir a mil kilómetros por
hora a 10.000 pies de altura 10.000
metros de altura pero 90 de cada 100
hasta un metro y medio casi en estado de
reposo los miedos son los miedos son
irracionales de acuerdo pero cuando se
vencen aparece esto placer
satisfacción lo logré orgullo una
sensación de auto-confianza
impresionante que loca es la
comunicación porque por un lado nos
produce angustia atención y por otro
lado cuando lo logramos nos puede dar
emociones totalmente positivas ahora
todo muy lindo no vencer el miedo la
confianza el romanticismo pero toda
disciplina necesita de un método y sal
la sal y la transpiración el ensayo el
prueba y error los samuráis hace muchos
siglos decían transpiró en el
entrenamiento para no sangrar en la
batalla trans pero en el entrenamiento
para no sangrar en la batalla sin
transpiración es muy difícil y ahí sí
aplicar un método un método que tiene
reglas leyes recuerdan estas cinco
cuando tengan que hacer una comunicación
o hablar en público ley del uno dos uno
o dos objetivos nunca 8 la gente no la
recuerda uno o dos grandes cosas segundo
ley de principio y de final no
transmitamos un powerpoint
no nos llenemos como si estuviese
memorizado un vuelo de despegue vuelo
desarrollo y aterrizaje y la tercera
regla es la conclusión en el aterrizaje
y si es una conclusión tiene que tener
un verbo si nuestra intención es
comunicar persuadir no sólo informar
tiene que haber un verbo que es una
palabra castellana que terminen ar er
oír mover a alcanzar lo que sea el verbo
moviliza el pensamiento la acción y el
sentimiento si no hay un verbo no va a
haber comunicación ley de las imágenes
gráficas no transmitamos palabras las
palabras en sí misma tiene poco valor lo
que tiene valor es lo que está detrás de
la palabra las imágenes los recuerdos y
ley de lara argumento refuerzo argumento
refuerzo en una comunicación sólida
precisa profesional el argumento tiene
que estar porque lo que da el dato la
evidencia pero el refuerzo tiene que
estar citas anécdotas historias humor
storytelling participaciones del público
tiene que haber refuerzos el refuerzo
gráfica lo que el argumento no logran y
el refuerzo tiene que tener emociones
tiene que haber emociones que apunten a
las sensaciones a lo sensorial a los
recuerdos
la abuela no hacía pasta los domingos la
abuela hacía arte en sus espacios los
días domingo transformaba 3 o 4 tomates
en una salsa deliciosa inevitable mojar
con el pancito
transformaba harina y agua en unos
fideos artísticos y texturados que al
día de hoy no podemos olvidar el
asentimiento y su sonrisa con el plato
sobre la mesa cuando nos levantábamos
nos confirmaban y nos confirman que esos
recuerdos son inolvidables imborrables y
tal vez los mejores emociones
pero cuidado cuando hablamos de
comunicación no estamos hablando de
monologar el monólogo es una lanza
informativa y el público en general en
el año 2021 ya no quiere información
quiere soluciones quieres consejos
recetas tips historias
por eso cuidado con monologar
dialoguemos para invitar al público que
sea parte para participar hay una
investigación muy interesante que dice
una persona en promedio recuerda el 10%
de lo que escucha una persona recuerda
el 30% de lo que escucha de una persona
en promedio recuerda el 50 de lo que
escucha ve y participa y el 90 de lo que
escucha ve participa ya se acciona
interviene
vamos al colegio profesores recuerden
aquel que llegaba dejaba el maletín
hablaba agarraba el maletín y se iba 10
% recuerden aquellos tutores baquianos
docentes maestros que nos hacían formar
parte del acto de comunicación
esos son verdaderos comunicadores y esta
pregunta me encanta porque hay uno dice
que tienen los grandes comunicadores
somos todos potencialmente buenos
comunicadores es que hacen y hacen cinco
cositas más dos las cinco cosas son
planificar nadie planifica fracasar si
fracasa por no planificar la segunda
estructura
no cuentan un lienzo sonoro un
powerpoint hacen un viaje que tiene
argumentos y emociones pausa hacen esto
no me quedé sin sonido el streaming
funciona bien hacen pausas para hacer
pensar para hacer sentir para pensar
después de un argumento para sentir
después de un refuerzo la palabra no
rellena es la segunda palabra más poder
perdonar el silencio en la segunda
palabra más poderosa del mundo
pausa silencios la cuarta se vinculan
con el público ninguno de los presentes
ni ahí detrás nos enamoramos de nuestras
parejas mirándole los cordones o los
codos nos enamoramos mirando a los ojos
generen un vínculo emocional
iniciado en el vínculo visual
tenemos que generar un vínculo con el
público y se relacionan trabajan por
feedback si las cosas no saben bien no
hay señales de fatiga cambian para darle
al público lo que el público necesita no
lo que el público desea y hacen dos
cosas muy interesantes la primera miren
esa imagen confían
el 9 de ronaldo no el actual el anterior
confía él confía que ronaldo con fe y si
tenemos miedo a vencerlo y si no lo
podemos vencer a disimularlo pero para
el cerebro es terriblemente poderoso el
intento la intención el intentarlo y por
último tienen pasión intenten hablar de
lo que les gusta decir lo que quieran si
lo saben cuando se cruzan conocimiento y
disfrute sólo queda pasión y las cosas
no pueden salir mal
las presentaciones tienen que hacerse
hay
en comunicación y muchísimas actividades
un virus terrible que no es el comité es
el algún día algún día voy a aprender a
tocar el piano algún día voy a ser feliz
el día que me jubile voy a algún día voy
a emprender algún día voy a hacer esa
presentación que tengo pendiente en
algún día es hoy no es mañana no es
pasado algún día me voy a recibir algún
día voy a hacer la dieta es hoy y la
realidad es que hay pocos discursos
presentaciones a comunicaciones que
realmente cambiaron el mundo hay java
twin sangre sudor y lágrimas y es
weekend conecta los puntos en de tu cama
ya no quiero hacer presentaciones para
cambiar el mundo yo quiero hacer
comunicaciones y presentaciones para
cambiar nuestros
por eso saben qué significa comunicar y
comunicar es compartir comunicar no es
informar comunicar no es expresar
comunicar no es simplemente contar
comunicar es compartir y compartir
significa poner en común hace unos 78
minutos les dije que una de las reglas
de la comunicación era tener una
conclusión con un verbo bueno ahí va
este es mi verbos para ustedes
anímate intentarlo todos y todas podemos
hablar en público muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]